un château c'est atteignable à tout le
monde pour tout le monde parce qu'il ya
des châteaux kizomba 300000 euros le
prix d'une maison et après si vous
voulez il ya toute une logique de mise
en place pour pouvoir être aidées se
faire aider être accompagné rénover ce
château j'ai acheté donc en 2016
la forteresse de saint vidal qui est une
forteresse médiévale très ancienne et
l'une des mieux conservés de la région
auvergne
cette vieille forteresse médiévale qui
était très abîmé ces sites est d'être
rénovée réhabiliter intégralement j'ai
construit ce projet autour des
spectacles autour de l'animation
culturelle du lieu
fort de ce premier succès j'ai souhaité
déployer un deuxième projet à travers le
château de la barben mille ans
d'histoire jean chez sur ce rocher
propriété des moines de l'abbaye de
saint victor du roi rené d'anjou de la
famille de forbin pendant 500 ans qui a
permis à rattacher la le comté de
provence au royaume de france
en auvergne avec saint vidal rayonnement
de la culture auvergnate en provence à
rayonnement de la culture provençale
hélas que ce qu'il faut imaginer si vous
voyez le château mais voyez si je vous
retourne la caméra regardez là vous avez
une vue derrière avec les albi et là par
contre je suis perchée sur un rocher 200
m voyez dans le rocher il ya des salles
en trombe l'audit est tout et puis après
plus vous montez dans les couches plus
vous avez les époques qui succèdent
jusqu'à une partie qui est même début
20e et à chaque siècle qui a eu des
ajouts mais au niveau des chambres
lyonnais il y en a peu une dizaine dit
pour la surface du château c'est pas
grand quoi 5500 mètres carrés bateau de
cette envergure en provence avec cette
surface il y en a un tous les trente ans
qui sort il y en a très très peu la
réalité en étant pragmatique sur
l'acquisition d'un tel lieu ce sont des
lieux qui ça dépend des régions peuvent
et plus ou moins cher et surtout qui
nécessite beaucoup plus d'argent
la rénovation de réhabilitation que
globalement dans la queue devant
l'acquisition souvent ce qu'on présente
c'est des mecs qui crèvent de faim
pendant 22 ans qui se tape un vieux
cailloux et on se dit c'est l'horreur
c'est le cauchemar il faut que je me
tape tous les week-ends à reprendre les
volets électricité qui fout le camp là
il ya eu tous les plats qui nous tombe
sur la gueule quand on rentre dans la
pièce passé le cauchemar est donc en
fait moi je déteste cette approche là
parce que la réalité c'est qu'il ya
plein de levier pour pouvoir être aidées
il ya plein de gens qui sont sensibles à
cette cause là un château c'est
atteignable à tout le monde pour tout le
monde parce qu'il ya des châteaux
kizomba 300000 euros le prix d'une
maison et après si vous voulez il ya
toute une logique de mise en place pour
pouvoir être aidées se faire aider être
accompagné rénover ce château si on sent
qu'on n'a pas les épaules de proma
château de 5500 mètres carrés il faut
acheter un château qu'en fait 300 ça
existe aussi il y en a des rallyes cent
et quelques jours on disait l'adhésion
de la population gc notre château
c'est pas le nôtre sur le papier mais
notre dans l'histoire et on est tous
attachés je crois que c'est des cerveaux
le coup quoi
[Musique]